the next few years where we're doing
commercials and endless commercials and
all the money I never declared a profit
we just took the profits and put back
into the training in the picture and I
was running a permanent staff and it was
getting bigger and bigger
along came the rabbit a job and it was
offered and they seconded my studio and
I knew that the studio would disappear
into the arms of Disney and Spielberg
who were in this loose marriage to make
the rapper Roger Rabbit that was easy
I said to Bob Zemeckis I said because he
bub wouldn't issued a modern movie and
and he said all these animation
directors we've talked to just said they
they want a locked-off camera like the
Mary Poppins you know defend X dancing
the camera steady and he said I wonder
we do modern movies these days and I
said well sure we just draw the round he
said what do you mean I'm you it'd be a
lot of drawings they said we have to
draw every frame you just print up the
live action and we put a rabbit in it's
a little more complicated than that
and we figured out how to do the because
Iowa Industrial Light and Magic Ken
Ralston marvelous guy had they could
print in the Star Wars movie with the
motorbikes shooting through the trees
they were able to print on the optical
printer print they didn't look pasted it
on like Tony Tiger used to me you know
like it was on glass and so you could
see what's gonna works and we figured
out how to make it two and a half
dimensional that was the problem it was
just a lot of work and I said we need as
much time as we can get and and we'll
just do as many you know would just turn
we're supposed to be able to turn things
that's our job so we just whatever you
shoot we did so I was on the shoots at
the beginning but it was obvious you
don't need me he knew what to do just
leave a space for a rabbit and that was
that was it or Jessica
so that way that was I used to stand at
my door every now and then and yell draw
faster some of the guys here I see you
we were on that that's what it was a
race
another bloody race